[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
yeah we are live baby
welcome to the lions den the lions den
by money lion
forget your intros man we're here with
the boys forget your intro we're at the
super bowl we're at the super bowl and
we're at mike type mike you got a nice
house man thanks for having me
this is a beautiful great house man i
got it on the market you're interested
in buying
that's good how much how much i think 12
12 oh you go
that's hey
lenny kravitz had something to do with
it i think they designed it that's what
they said
i guess they want me doing the intro but
i feel like i mean come on right direct
to my left daniel cormier
light heavyweight champion heavyweight
champion analyst extraordinaire after
ufc brandon marshall all pro badass
podcast game
and now now i'm i'll give out your other
accolades with you know but really
you're jumping the heavy weight the
better heavier weight in the world oh
wow ufc we talking about unifying the
divisions if you want to go boxing and
there's a conversation between is boxing
on it down or is it ufc on the up it
doesn't matter i take on cormier i'll
take on mike tyson
right here
we'll see what's up at half time
right here right here the man all the
way at the end the legend the one the
only iron mike tyson thank you yeah
thanks for having us brother appreciate
you man
appreciate you so listen the big the
mangoes are gonna kill these guys okay
you think the bangalore's gonna get that
money on me oh wow you've got a lot of
money money on anything why are you that
why are you so sure mike i ain't feeling
dangerous
that feels dangerous
but mike this is this is where it it
it's a conflict of interest because i'm
a rams fan but now i know you got all
this money on it i can't root again if
you put all this money on it hey it's
the whole it's about the excitement of
the game yeah i feel you you're no ram
fan
you're a broncos fan don't pull this
[ __ ] on us though don't do this i live
in los angeles [ __ ] that now i'm around
i've been there you thought but still
you didn't like this before they got
this good no you're right
what do you think you're doing
listen they come out the rams right now
are coming out conservative that's what
three running plays in a row
you know they're trying to ease into the
game
nerves you know this man nerves are high
how many times you had millions of
people watching you see this one right
here henderson come on
but you was a little guy you was a
little guy moving big guys you know what
i don't matter exactly that's why i'm
there you go
you got to think about leaving what mike
just said you know he talking about
little guy moving the big guy
i mean yeah don't matter it's about your
technique it's about your feet work this
is what's there
how do you how do you do it if you see a
fighter you see a football player
how do you measure their heart their
will how do we do that we do that by
their dedication look at that dedication
i can't really hear
what they're willing to do in the other
play tonight i can't hear mike at all
man
hey brandon let me ask you this
who would you rather played for he had
stafford who's obviously bombs over
baghdad just joe burrow or joe burrow
joe i'm running away i'm going with run
baby look at the movie yeah because
think about like um
i love his swagger
you know and i also he can do it all i
mean his football iq is through the roof
he can make every throw on the field but
i need a i need a quarterback that's
also
gonna
go out to dinner with me i need a
quarterback that's also going to come to
the crib and chill have you ever played
with a quarterback that did that for you
yeah jay cutler was one ryan uh ryan uh
uh uh fitzpatrick i love ryan russell
wilson i had a couple guys but but to
see the the the things with me i had 17
different quarterbacks 17 17
can't really build that relationship
wait two minutes you know
brenda let me ask him a question
the rams just came off conservative
here's my i always wonder about this is
football they get that they get the
third long and they always run the ball
right why
it's like they don't try to get the
first down because statistics right like
you know when we go wednesday we sit
down and we put in our we start putting
our game plan thursday is when we do
third down okay so thursday we're only
working on third down and we're looking
at third and short what is third and
short first and first of three yards uh
third and medium six to seven third and
long 10 11 so we're putting in three or
four points you never want to be in
third and long because statistically
speaking like you're only going to
convert those probably 10 of the time
right so
you don't want to make a bad situation
worse you don't want to go out there and
throw and get an interception it makes
the game worse so what we do we do draws
we do screens yeah every single time
every single time it's just statistic
things like we're looking at the numbers
yeah conversion to be really good on
third down we need to be converting and
these are super bowl teams and both of
them are
fifty percent of the time we need to be
converting on third down yeah but that's
the problem is like because everybody
does the same thing they never get third
down very right because every time you
throw the screen they they're ready for
it yeah but you're looking at we know
that going in we know these screens and
these run plays it's all good we're just
trying not to make the situation worse
okay but if it's third and short oh yeah
we're getting after if it started medium
we're getting after third and long
most teams are saying
we'll live to see another another series
mangoes bango bang girl
now i'm stressed out now i gotta root
for the [ __ ] baby
[Music]
they got [ __ ] at that mercy neck all
the time get cold for us we gotta go out
in the cold and get some money right
fellas they're giving out some cash too
man my friends that money line download
the money line app right now get your
money war tag going good that's my
money's good
i'm betting with the bank
every quarter a hundred grand man with
money line make money watch super bowl
with this download
i can make a bet every quarter
you're to make a bet every quarter mike
is it possible yeah you go over your
bingos that go joe burrow right here joe
burrow
joe
lsu
lsu's own joe mad joey they're going
gonna win the game
i'm gonna win the game
mike talk to me about mindset you know
why they're going to win the game
because the other team came out ran the
ball three times in a row
and they came out throwing the ball
don't worry why do you think they're
concerned
because they can't get democratic
because they're holding them to concern
we always fighting when y'all fighting
do y'all ease into the fights or are
y'all coming out
right out of there
he's got to go he was more his iq was
higher i watched some knockouts
loosey goosey i was short
so i had to kind of attack people right
right i was i was the team that didn't
have the the talent right i was the kid
i was the guy that needed to go and put
pressure on people
because if i stand back i was fighting
that light heavyweight in heaven right
dude it's all but also
but also for dc
if you rush and you try to blitz these
seasons
right right we're taking out the guys
coming
so the thing was they were trying to
stay on the outside so i would have to
be the advancing party because if not
they're kind of just picking me chipping
me three yards
but think about this situation though
right now you got the la rams they got
all the biggest stars in the world and
they came out playing conservative right
yep you got the cincinnati bengals yeah
and they come out and did they get the
first down oh i don't get the first down
didn't get it but they don't pass it to
me that says a lot about their mindset
and they have that first down yeah but
now now they're getting momentum so i'm
on a third down now they're gonna put
right i mean you're a little more lucy
this time a little more loosey-goosey
and then also
what i love about the rams you gotta
decide are you gonna double cooper cup
who's the best chief in the nfl and then
leave old el beckham one-on-one you know
what i'm saying that's right that's a
good deal that's a great point you gotta
think about this you can't you can't and
this is where matthew stafford had to do
a phenomenal job
of protecting the football and making
the right decision oh they're going for
it on fourth down guys
that's what i'm talking about listen
though and they're throwing the ball oh
oh
oh he forced him to chase rams
hey he forced it in the chase
he never looked at anybody
else he didn't look at everybody
he looked at chase the entire time
they [ __ ] fat but they don't [ __ ] long
okay
yo he looked at chase the whole time the
whole time running back field that was
wide open yeah they're running back
enough yeah
brandon that's why yeah you said you'd
rather play for joe burr i know he's a
great quarterback if you play for the
rams we had cooper cup on the other side
no you're getting one-on-one coverage
ding ding ding well go back to 2018
brandon why are you going to the giants
why because odell beckham is over on
this yeah
he's going to get double now i'm going
to be backside one-on-one
so it's exactly what you said what do
you do if you're a defensive coordinator
but the interesting thing about this
matchup
is that they're not playing a lot of
man-to-man they're going to play zone so
they're not going to go and match up and
yeah they got they got they got a lean
coverage they got to take out odell
cooper cup double him on third down
double odell on first down oh wow
because because that was the big play
cooper cup is going to beat you no no no
they both big play both
bigfoot yeah yeah they both because
cooper cup is something we've never seen
like the 49ers that last week like come
on how does that happen come on bro what
the [ __ ] were the db's doing from the
niners come on man how you can beat that
bass oh my goodness i don't smoke
take the tv smoke teach me does he smoke
you smoke weed my tights don't smoke
weed
really really
even when you're five weeks in the world
that's why i stopped and i lost the
olympic job
the poison from frogs you still mess
with them frogs
the psychedelic frogs every day every
time i get a chance
why are you taking it it make you like
you know hey i got a buddy that he loves
it
he's just like it took him on a trip
that he's never like he will tell
everybody about it now really he is
literally the spokesperson for doing
that so so
you seem like a button but i was i'm
like i'm not doing it it's not in my
personality because i don't know
if i'm end up running around like butt
ass naked
crazy [ __ ]
and then espn gonna be called like hey
yeah
i work for them
you answered
[Laughter]
they're like yo you're not even running
through la you're running through san
jose but has negatives on the street
look at him right he locked in on chase
the whole time
take the flat you only need one
and you see ramsey them dudes all they
they they bracketed that was a iffy call
i don't know if you make that call this
early in the game
here's the thing i think it speaks to
the mentality of the teams right because
cincinnati's not supposed to be here now
they're not building playing with house
money they're playing with houses
yeah let's go baby go fill that hole
they playing with house money yeah no
running
it's like
the rams are built to win today
they're built to win today we're stacked
but not
not the uh
the bengals aren't supposed to be no
because living in l.a the ram every rams
game is on yeah they take games off
they're so talented yeah they just take
games off
no staffing
hurt and uh
that didn't look good just now
yeah
i don't like how they protect the
quarterbacks so much now the tom brady
rule this this whole they don't let
these dudes tackle the quarterbacks at
all
well they're pretty even when you're
falling like you could fall and like
fall into the guy's legs a little bit
that's a penalty
bad that's not good
third and four let's go rams all right
here we go so where are we at we got
third and four this is short this is
third and short you're talking about
what seventy percent of the time you're
gonna see one on one
okay like let's see do we have
one-on-one coverage so now you got
stafford looking at cooper cup as his
number one option come on cooper cupping
come on go get that guy
go go see listen think about this this
is what make this guy special he wasn't
even the number one option right here
but he caught the ball behind the sticks
and he made a guy miss we call that yak
daddy's yes daddy's
oh my goodness look at this but look
that's the difference right that's the
difference in stafford and burrow
burrell he wasn't the number one option
bro was locked on chase this dude went
through he just moved on got it over the
cooper cup that's right
he didn't move though
yep
receivers in detroit where you know
calvin johnson those guys one year
removed
big [ __ ] he's a grown man look
at him
so much
the beard
like he 50.
all right here we go with the situation
we're in the red zone right now it's
second to six this is a perfect time for
a run okay
perfect time for a run or you just throw
a quick game quick game is anything five
yards or less
because you guys come on get him
so the reason why this is good we call
this
we're we're
we're in we're in we're in routine we're
on pace we're just trying to get on the
board the only thing we're trying to do
on offense
is trying to get to third and short
third and manageable
that's it there you go so now you're
third and three you need to be
converting third and three at like 70
70
conversion
these are the things that we think about
and now we work through throughout the
week people think we just go out and
play football we'll go out there and
play football it's like we spend more
time studying
than we do actually practicing i don't
play football no more right not in
practice all right here you go we got mp
formation by two cooper cup going on one
what is covered up doing cooper jump
about to get a touchdown oh oh damn
oh oh no do it mike do it mike do it
he's incredible why is he incredible
because listen he's the consummate
professional you know every time you see
him he's constantly in shape he's never
out of shape right
[Applause]
yeah apples that tadpole uh
roll it up let's roll it out roll it up
you're gonna be the only one smoking
he's the only one wrong he worked for
the mouse he worked for you
smoke i don't smoke me on smoke
it's just not my thing yeah it's not his
thing i like whiskey man bourbon yeah
i always see you posting that about
whispering
all kind of
here's the question are we still on
right now
are we still rolling all right good
here's the question
do you roll your own blunts
or do somebody else you have a guy mike
he's a full-time job he is the guy that
makes hundreds
mike
you guys
mike
he rolls your [ __ ]
yeah that's a full-time job what's his
name what's his or her name what's her
name troy troy
is he good at what he does no tight mic
best ever
what makes a good uh uh blunt roller
uh mike don't smoke blood to smoke
joints
periodically free rolls
no i have my own
on my own blunts
mike tyson man got a his own roller no
you have to look up tyson 2.0
what's tyson 2.0 it's the biggest league
cup in the world
the biggest league company in the world
check it out man i got them in 18 states
yeah no no no no
18th state listen mike's the elon musk
and reid really yeah
yeah but the coolest thing about
fighting is that there's two seconds oh
yeah you do mushrooms
i'm on my shoes now
i'm high right now well educate the
people how do we do see you know the
science behind it mike you know the
science you got you're educated why is
this stuff important to you
it's a connection and the connection
with the divine leadership you have a
connection with god
mike doesn't it doesn't bring you down a
level two like you run at 10 when you're
on psychedelics
it makes you more human they could [ __ ]
with you really he could [ __ ] with you
make you
it could it could build you up and stop
bringing some
grimy stuff
[Laughter]
hopefully uh hopefully none of those
demons come out mike you start attacking
people not today
hey mike you ever get too high and like
tigers and [ __ ] still or no say what you
ever get too high and make crazy
purchases
no
absolutely man
what's that what's the what's the
craziest purchase you've made over the
last two years you're like cause you've
been in your bag the last two years i've
been good i've been doing that but like
um
buy property
you buying
[Applause]
listen think about how amazing that is
right the mike tyson to me when you talk
about i got my own roller but then you
go back to with mike tyson the big crib
and the lions and the tigers in the back
whatever and now we made rolls-royce a
legendary story going through the
through the toll a dude didn't have a
car and mike said here take my keys it
was a rolls-royce is that true oh listen
to this one that's a true story no
no no it happened
i was um
i was married the first time i'm only 21
years old i'm married my wife i go into
a restaurant with my wife a fat food
drink hungry she goes in my pocket to
get the money she pulls out some condoms
she gets in my car the rolls royce and
she rams it into some other car breaks
the guy's arm right
and so
all of a sudden she's screaming the cops
come up
i don't want the cops to lock up so the
guys think my arm is broken right my arm
is broken
the first guy i gave some money stack of
my mother ten thousand i'll take it
right he went into off track bet and
start betting and one guy came up
and said oh my arm is broken i told the
cops and huh cuz you can have this man
it's all good i got too much [ __ ] you
guys work hard to risk your life take
the car and when the guy said
sir my arm is broken hey i'm telling you
one more [ __ ] time to [ __ ] up my face
my right hand a lot of cops said that
because he heard that car once he said
once he did that i thought i know i'm
out of it i didn't want my wife to get
arrested she just broke [ __ ] the guy up
ran into his car who was the wife at the
time what's her name you know [ __ ]
robin gave me yeah
she's your mic
hey joe my boy crazy right yeah yeah
but you know what let's do that
but here's what's dope about it this is
what i love about you and your journey
mike is that okay boom that's where we
were 20 30 years ago but now you talk
about disposable income and now you're
buying properties and businesses and you
talking about your own
marijuana company right
so listen though listen
if you don't have nothing worth losing
all that [ __ ] you don't have nothing
right you have to have something that's
worth tearing yourself down right
all right here we go get back to
football third and fourth did i teach
you now he's in these games
you know what you know what joe is a
little flustered he's a little off no
you didn't get started yet
all right fellas remember we're giving
away 25k a quarter that's a hundred
thousand dollars in the super bowl
download the money line app right now
we're giving away 25 bangles
come on bangla like money might give
everyone that comes from mike that's all
my personal bank account come on
brandon's giving a hundred thousand
dollars he's not trying hard enough they
had they had what they wanted yep you
got one-on-one what did i say
you're going to get one-on-one coverage
monoi mono 70 of the time yep they got
exactly what you they wanted and he
didn't hit it
the running back got caught up he got
tripped but he had it now we call that a
big box fade it was perfect let's feel
like in the same way especially
capitalized man
that was just a situation where the
running back feet got tangled with the
linebackers yep you know so they're
right i think mike might be about to
give up nah good night's out still come
on
[ __ ] yeah it's just started it just
started it just
that's right see he used to go on what
is it three we only go five yeah 25
minutes that's the difference it's
different these dudes go 36.
that 36 minutes is is a nightmare right
but the three-minute round three-minute
rounds but listen though i feel like the
three-minute round makes you want to
fight harder because it's shorter but
they don't really get started six rounds
mike mike what was the mentality going
into round 10 11 12.
i don't gotta wear this guy down
trying to wear the other guy there
what he got late yeah avoid as many
punches as possible of course
punching to the body to the body hey
mike let me ask you this you know tyson
fury and francis nagano
pretty sure they're going to fight a
year from now they're going to fight
how's that go down with francis and
tyson fury oh man no bro hey you know
what's crazy hold on i can't everything
let me just say this before mike answers
let me just say this mike you better not
give me a company answer bro i listen no
shut up
listen
bro watching watching the fight
against uh cyril
i'm watching it and i'm thinking to
myself love francis
can't box no tyson fury you get a blown
out mclaren don't matter no it's a
difference right mike you agree michael
no absolutely listen
you had a blown out mcl 24-0
24-0 he had an mcl acl
right leg
three weeks before the fight still
beating he out he you know he took his
heart he took cyril's heart a little bit
because listen right
man for man he can't beat cyril
he can't beat him in a straight up fight
free fight man for man he got to get him
he had to rough them up i look you like
that
yeah mike i saw
you can't fight that guy he can't fight
that guy head up no he's there for
losing games mike but that's part of the
fight to take down yes but you love the
takedown because when you're standing
you come up out of your seat you jump
and i know there's a point you know and
i know he can't fight this guy mike
jumped there with michael he can't fight
that guy heading up like that i'm
looking directly at my my jump out of
the seat and went crazy up in there so
so you boys don't want to see francis
with tyson i just think that a box
francis of course i want to see it yeah
of course i want to watch it but i'm
just saying i don't know france will
make a lot of money that's what we want
yes france will make a ton of money i
just want no people don't know this
boxing [ __ ] is tricky why is it true
i go like that i said listen do this put
him in there with a a golden gloves or a
national champion a heavyweight division
no we need money just let him smile
we'll spar with him we need money let
him spawn first
mike you ever had those guys those guys
that throw those big shots like francis
because francis can get a bit wide at
times
if he lands knock you off those guys
though you kind of touch them up yes
that's true but
you got to be careful with the other
guys coming too that's what i'm saying
you got to anticipate this punch by
punching and moving after you punch i'm
saying if you fought a guy like francis
that throws wide like that you inside
all right
but but then also let's not get twist
some weird world and francis lance
on tyson it's so i'm nice and furious oh
really it's too hot can't there's
something really
rough you know how many professional
guys that punch
hard tried to hit him and can't do it i
know yo that's what i was gonna say
right fury he's seen that
fury scene francis because he fought
deontay he's kind of seen a version of
you having the wrong conversation right
now why because the conversation and the
question right now is mike tyson in his
prime versus fury in his prime who wins
mike
that's the question
mike before the answer this is no
disrespect to me
technically wise fury can go he can go
defense his footwork she's big to me as
far as technique wise fear's the best
we've ever had oh wow what you doing
tyson hits the hardest treatment mike
he might try to lean on you might try to
grab you lean on you i don't know he's
rude right now michael's like i'm tired
of you being so honorable so
fury in his prime enticing this crime
who wins tell the people the truth
listen
listen
just him being tighty fairy shows my
greatness
my great yeah it shows his greatness
hey that's good
after after mike
yeah mike that's a great answer i don't
want to know i don't care if he could
beat me or not
he named after his name is tyson his
name is tyson and his dad i don't care
he could beat me he could beat me i
don't care the name of tyson named after
the greatest fighter ever lived greatest
that was the that was the greatest
that's the one right i love mike tyson
he's one of my best friends in the world
now we got some philadelphia eagles fans
who's
this
a drake look alike coming got a white
jacket
he didn't like drake didn't he
all right here we go
come on marshall
still in the first quarter there's
[Laughter]
so listen here's the situation we're
still in the first quarter b two minutes
left we're in sunny
man
the heat index is out in this world
right now it's never been this hot in
l.a this time of year well hydration
yes we want to eat
come on get some of this everything
you know what i ain't looking like
you know what i'm going for
blueberries he went for blueberries
might help him
mike mikey
thank you
what the [ __ ] are we doing in there
you're eating blueberries and chilling
man you want some some great friends i'm
straightening better get some grease man
have a couple grapes man
get your energy up
let's go let's go two rounds real quick
[Laughter]
you got some good cardio mike yeah
are you ready for us man
dc you know i got it we got to bring it
up last night's ufc that you worked
robert whittaker izzy
decision yeah robbie whitaker he's gonna
have a tough fight again yeah you're
gonna stop fighting i i watched it this
morning i had you guys
i tried i was like
right there
hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
on this shot mike it looked like you got
a body shot over the left he had a right
hand about to drop him again check this
out look look mike it looks like you
might have had your beat buddy come on
i'll get one i'll give him another
opportunity i'll give him another
opportunity mike it looked like he had
you i ain't [ __ ] with him
[Laughter]
i don't know
[Laughter]
oh here you go mike tyson getting makeup
of course he got his own professional
roller
he has lions and tigers
[Applause]
check it out that's one on one was it
first down because we were boxing
go around second down
marsh one hand
one
talking about greatness this is
greatness
oh my god picture mike that's
understatement fix your mic marshall
they say that when you go they say when
ramsay
they say when ramsay play aside and shut
down this side oh it's going down right
now
going down right now oh
[Applause]
mike talk about greatness we're in the
super bowl was first down
he catches a bomb on jaylen ramsay the
best cornerback
in the nfl the last three years not just
this year closest thing we have
greatness it's gonna be a war
not gonna be easy games that's what we
want i want a high scoring back and
forth we don't want this [ __ ] to be
boring
look at that so they got to finish
listen
this you can't what is that called what
is that calling the ball
that's just a batted pass isn't that
crazy that they got von miller
and aaron donald next to each other on
that side
russia got a free hit oh my goodness
knee that boy
that was [ __ ]
yeah let's do that or hit him low but
listen look how hard it is now we're
third and ten again what do you do if
you're in the situation run the ball
you're in the red zone
or do you know you gotta take your
points you gotta take points after what
you told me after what you told me ten
percent completion so here's the biggest
thing
i'm running the ball
so they're going to play the front of
the end zone look at the safeties
they're at the front of the end zone
they got down there but they couldn't
score now you got to kick three
it's good this is a win for the
cincinnati bengals but it's hard once
you get into tight red when you're
inside this point when you're inside of
the fifth team we call this the titan
rings
man i you can't go you'll go for
touchdowns
but early you gotta get your man put up
points
so jaylen ramsey gives up a big play
then he comes down and he stops them
fully redeemed himself you gotta listen
next
next next next play
y'all got time to look well we got three
you got three right there should come
over here how did i know that carpet
little girls guys that's like carpet
or did you take it
out
okay all right
all right
straight up bet huh great job higgins
[Music]
he almost accepted that he had it no he
didn't
he didn't danger
he undercut him look no he hold him
here's the thing when i played against
darrell reeves i played against bailey
the best of the best
you have literally a half a second
to actually beat them
well i used to tell my quarterbacks if i
ran out slant that same slant against
darrell reeves if you don't throw it
before i even come out my break it's all
the balls going the other way jayla
ramsey almost picked that ball off when
you're going against elite cornerbacks
man the timing is everything
tell me i don't get inside leverage on
this boy man you don't mind don't get
inside leveraging this boy
i don't get it i'm not wide receiver but
tell me
this guy man
hey
i didn't know it was you i was looking
at you i'm [ __ ] up
look i said man put it right there man
oh my god this ball is the inside huh oh
my goodness
he couldn't even move then he said
that's the best one i said you might
want me to get a [ __ ] i might call for a
fade run right right marshall
anybody want ginger ale
man thank you mike you're not getting
out of here
is that your company you know that last
time you owned a ginger rail company
yeah i rewatched this morning i did a
fight command last night i was drinking
yeah i got it
yeah
i have a dream company because he won
that fight i think four to one money man
are you three to two tysons
tyson 2.0 because i thought that
mike tyson everybody won the first time
very clearly clearly
the second round i thought that robert
whitaker could have won the round
because he had his back third round i
thought he won 100 fourth round is he
one
whitaker won round five that was his
best round yep so i thought it was three
to two that's fair but the problem is
the judges some judges gave rob round
three
that's the problem that's because they
don't put any value in the like kids
they got some bad jokes
they got some bad judges man
like you told me this morning like man
did you see that fight as close to
everybody else i was like when i watch
it like i don't see the
issue at all well when i walked when i
walked in there the interview
i figured izzy had one i just didn't
know how much he had one box
i didn't know if it was recruited two or
four to one but i thought izzy won the
fight yeah i was like there was no like
so when the crowd reacts in the way that
they did they're booing
i was surprised i was like wow i was
like maybe i was watching a different
fight
but
48 47 48 47 49 46 all for
israel
israel
operating on a different level
just grabs his [ __ ] hand bro paper i
swear to god it was the sickest i love
him israel is out there having way too
much fun he's a superstar
he's just grabbing his brother he
grabbed his hand bro like you beat him
up black paper rock paper scissors no
he's like beat you already like it's
over i already got you bro he's having
too much fun
in the most luck
is he caught two dubs last night look
he's been raped
i mean come on man
this is the most intense
[Music]
i can't say he's not beating him
cannondale has a chance but but
on first look you're like man fight
who's beating is that 185 nobody has it
nobody has been
all right so it's the best we have to
offer
since we're talking about uh fighting
mike come back
come back
so we're talking about
fighting at the super bowl there's 150
million people tuning in to this super
bowl
i got a question for mike
mike
is this jake paul fight going down yes
or no
oh wow
it was logan paul i think right is it
logan or jake
let me check the next um
i didn't see the last check that they
offered me
what was the last check they offered you
it wasn't enough it wasn't enough not
enough to get mike out there
what is enough mike what's the number
what's the number if i want to really
if i want to fight you what i got to
come up with
well you don't have to come up with much
you know
i think 25 million with you
hey mike listen though but there's no
threat what you said is there a threat
is there a threat in that fight with
jake paul
and me yeah there's no threat i don't
think so not me realistically i don't
think so
yeah i i don't know man i think those
kids those kids can fight a little
better than people want to give him
credit for him well you know logan's a
businessman he's just trying to make
money
he can actually fight better he can
fight better than they give him all
right here we go
this is important get him get him
oh wow looks like i gotta grab his ankle
real quick all right so all right here
we go we're third and long it started
eleven what's going on
right there is that yuri
everybody
oh my goodness brandon look at his hair
why you are fighting forget him
[Music]
no yeah
[Laughter]
you got really close
[Laughter]
hey brandon he is legit the most scary
contender
in the ufc right now that's your next
light heavyweight
100
i've called it for two years now 100 100
he's your next laptop
you're a [ __ ]
get a man here we go you want to sit
down here yeah please hey you're it
100
this guy's got some confidence in you
here we go guys we're in the red zone
the rams are getting scary
bro you're in shape dog how much you
weigh right now how much you weigh right
now
2 15 15. oh he's not even cutting no but
i want to be i want to be ready all the
time
[Laughter]
met my hey mike please meet this guy man
big pleasure to meet you all right
thank you bro
short shorts
easy crazy bro what he did what he did
to anthony smith was grace nuts he's the
real deal he's one of my
he's been around for a while why don't
you go
heavyweight jumps jumping and and he
idolizes you global moves like you do
he's a really good grappler
he's footwork he's unconventional
hey mike mike mike mike my eagle michael
touchdown i'm telling you you can't take
field goals for touchdowns
we're stopping them right here look at
the chance touchdown cooper come on
touchdown
our boy tyler just won 25 000
dollars from money life i'm telling you
now we're not messing around
tyler
from freaking i don't know where he's
from but that boy just won 25 25 000
money lines
let me hold something buddy this ain't a
game 20 of my money
yeah
money lying is throwing out the bread
what'd they say how much money is going
to be giving away 100 000
25 000 every quarter
you got to download the moneyline app
right now i'm telling you we just gave
away twenty five thousand dollars
you can wait download the app right now
moneyline app get your money more tag
going thoughts on social and comment on
your money war tag it's
that wasn't a fake that must have got
blocked because why would you ever try a
fake if you got a line up so far back
now
100 percent you don't do that you can't
feel it it had to get blocked something
happened between the all right the
center and the holder yeah
there's no way like so essentially when
they move the extra point back they've
eliminated the the the the fake the face
right that is total [ __ ] what's up
brother you're preparing for some for
some fight or it will be or not i've
been having a good time everybody
everybody asked me for that
are we still alive right now
[Music]
hey listen
[Music]
they're telling me you're the best one
the best i will be
no i'm not not yet because i'm coming
for that belt yeah i'm that that's just
me with him
i feel like i feel like b i feel like
he's too respectable right now he's too
humble ooh gary yeah hey when you get
out of here look up yuri and rising
machines that's the characteristics of a
real assassin quiet night oh yes brother
god is great
brandon
bro
wild boy wild boy yeah but i feel like
he should be calling i feel like you
should be calling mike out right now
indeed
d.c
i'm done
you know
just what
hey you know
hey you know that state that when you
like get too drunk you forget is on the
grill and then [ __ ] turn black that's
me
i'm done i'm overcooked and done you
done i'm done officially retired man i
retired two years ago almost never
coming back coming back
[Music]
we got
we got bubba wallace nascar legend
and bush coming up right now i'm telling
you i guess oh super ball gasps
man bubba wallace
yeah there's bubba wallace the legend
kurt busch legend what's up fellas how
you guys doing good luck john
brother get it done root for you
enjoy
hey go get em bro
don't forget me when i'm on ringside
that boy can look more european
yeah bro we got we have the nascar
legends up there right now
blessed legends
hey i don't think they can hear us they
can't hear we got you now
what's up fellas how you guys doing man
what up what up we're doing good how's
how's your super bowl sunday going
uh i didn't have any skin in the game so
i'd say mine's doing okay
i got i got a one-man party over here my
wife's getting ready we're going to
valentine's day dinner because we got
daytona rolling up oh that's right
that's a pretty big event that's a
legitimate visit
la's looking strong right now uh i i was
kind of pulling for cincinnati but
la's nellie's hot right now no bubba
don't do it i'm taking the bengals man
bubba jim mcmahon thing going on and i
love jim mcmahon and the chicago bears
and the 80s
all right make the pick who's going to
win this game
how you feel how are you cincinnati how
you fellas feeling for the daytona man
everything going well how do you guys
prepare for it
yeah we're feeling good ready to roar
moneyline is all about being alive
and we're ready to roar daytona and so
uh it's coming up here and it's uh it's
gonna be a lot of fun brand new cars
coming over teamed up for the toyota
side so it could be a lot of fun really
cool i got my i got my new backdrop
oh i love it kurt there you go dog
curt
can you hear me
kurt can you hear me
marshall we can barely hear you dog all
right y'all can barely hear me kurt i
got i got i got a confession
rowdy is my driver
and and bubba those are my drivers
i think how do you feel about that i i
think we oh there they are yeah there's
bubba he knows what's up hey listen
fellas don't come by marshall because
the moment you come next to me try to
fight russell he's got to fight every
person that has come over here
hey kurt you making a new move you're
going to a new team talk to us about
that new move brother
i'm digging it uh toyota asked me to
come in as a veteran and build a new
team up and build it alongside puppies
at 23-11. so the race with mk
denny hamlin all these guys uh this is
the perfect scenario for me as a as an
old school guy the veteran and i still
have that drive to win oh you saw that
bro
and just partnering up with a new group
of guys it's uh this is what it's all
about cool sponsors as well with monster
energy mcdonald's money lying and uh i
think it's going down baby
i love it i love it it's b sharp
we got dc
we got bubba wallace we got kurt bush we
got iron mike tyson here streaming live
this is legendary stuff
unbelievable money lion thank you so
much putting this together this amazing
event talk to me bubba wallace sure hey
history history
bro
you want talladega talk to us about that
moment
good night
pushing for the witness my free kickback
that was uh that was big a big color for
our team
uh just something to really build off of
especially
proud of everybody
and continuing to grow
and uh big things happened was
so fun to be covered my last part my
career
worked
most of it had responded bringing them
to the sixth grade bridge here
awesome
brother
i said bubba got that cricket wireless
connection
i don't know
i know bubba
is like bubbles
using his sponsor's phone
come on
get your internet right bubba you can't
like you can like take the sponsor's
money but not use them let me ask you
all questions cause we got some legends
on the deck
right now two legends nascar you guys
all right plate racing somebody tyson
mike tyson what's plate racing
beat the [ __ ] out of me
bubba bubba tell her what flight racing
is
vomit tell them
wait wait racing is uh it's drafting
it's valentine's night for everybody
seen all the movie talladega bags that
is playing amazing it's side by side x
buffer bumper action three and a half
hours
an hour
feeding banging
all right all right great great another
question it's like boxing with us
right right another question mike tyson
true or false
kyle
okay
rowdy
and kurt
are they related or not
the bush family i ain't saying nothing
about no butch man i just said kyle and
kurt
rowdy what's your nickname uh kurt
i i don't know i've been a bunch of
different names
the boss we gonna call you the boss yes
they're all family members they are yes
ding ding ding yes yes yes great job
great job they're freaking legendary and
they're from vegas
their father is phenomenal their father
helped him
yep
vegas in the house
hey kurt bubba we love you guys thanks
come on fellas good luck tomorrow man
for you
stay safe man and keep crushing both you
guys thanks for coming on
fellas appreciate that thank you
later you got it guys hey anybody that's
tuned in there's money up for grabs from
daytona so you got to register the money
line raising
there you go
they're giving money away during nascar
money money line all over we're in the
red zone again guys
we uh uh iron mike has a a lot of money
on the line for the the cincinnati
bengals he needs to be a good driver
okay six second and six now it's third
and short if i'm mike tyson we want a
touchdown here mike
we're in two down territory already yes
let me tell you why
if i'm in this situation right now
second quarter seven minutes to go
i run the ball on third down and then i
see what position i'm in and i'm and
i'll give myself a run pass option we
call those rpos on fourth down hey
brandon let me ask you this why is aaron
donald so good what's the deal aaron dar
step first off his mindset mike will
enjoy this this dude
is next level when it comes to mindset
he's a monster out there he's trying to
oh here we go here we go first down go
go another one
aaron donald is next level when it comes
to mindset 80 of the game 80 percent of
sport is in your mind it's mental
20 is physical so the physical he's next
level we're talking about a dude plays
deep into the line but he moves and runs
and he's built like a linebacker he's
jacked he's jacked
he's jacked but it all starts with his
mindset i saw aaron donald curse out a
guy on the field his own teammate i'm
playing against aaron donald when i'm
playing for the saints and our offensive
line is crushing
i'm playing for the seattle seahawks
they're crushing the la rams what are
they doing
and and aaron donner looks as his
defensive lineman next to him and says
if you play like this if you let them
treat you like this your ass cannot be
on this field with me oh wow that's what
he said to his own
man his mindset is next level
marshall how was it playing for the
saints how is playing the song
i'm just saying i'm from lafayette you
know i'm just asking how is it living in
like playing in this like a city like
that that's not one of my los angeles
one of my greatest football experiences
ever really oh my god
oh chick-fil-a let's get this money
money
let's get this money mike shadowbox
shadowbox let's get this money mike he
said it
i did it mike wins this mike has a
thousand psychedelic trucks
there's a lot of money there yeah
mushrooms around here the saints was
next level man one of my greatest
mushrooms in my car because it's not a
massive city
no but you have today ridiculous you
know how to party hey they kind of suck
now though
no they'll be yeah we lost them
fighting but
dennis allen you know he was a defensive
coordinator so he's been around
hopefully dennis allen is next level
yeah he's a great coach so hopefully
who's the starter now for you guys well
last year
baby uh it was james wednesday
good take home half case meal is fine
what is the other dude
hey whatever they're doubling my money
by putting down your double with my
money right
now you do those quarterback in the
states so james jameis winston james oh
you're talking about uh teddy
bridgewater no no no no no no no no
you're talking about um he played like
three games he was the worst quarterback
i've ever seen
oh man you know what i'm talking about
he was trash wasn't he oh my goodness we
went three and i fought in any team in
the nfl he had one good game
trevor simeon oh my goodness
trevor sent me he has everything
physically but that's less
mike y'all know this as fighters
it's not always the guys with the the
that's most gifted physically listen the
mentor is everything at that level
i was taught this about the mentor and
bodybuilding especially after you walk
away from the game it's everything you
know it i was taught this your body's on
your purpose to carry your brain
look at that mike's smart man mike god
damn it mike there's no strong zack
you're a philosopher like who do you
study what are you like where are you
getting this stuff from bro no you spit
games
on every show every podcast that you're
on
every time there's a camera in front of
you a mic in front of you you spit game
who are you studying bro i'm not saying
nobody everything i do
there's somebody's quotes but it's from
my experience in life i don't see nobody
quoting really some guys listen there's
some guys that never control a baton of
men an army and their quotes are more
legendary than god that actually fought
on the field yeah he's like a bruce lee
guy bruce lee never gotten anything
he never fought anybody but he fired so
many fighters yeah he did can you
believe that yeah and so that
that's good too because that's in that's
um that's contributing to fighting yeah
so you got just as good as fighting yeah
yeah i just watch i just watch his uh
his movies
oh like the last dragon oh my god
yeah he was the man to me to me the
greatest athlete no
is bruce lee
listen listen that's my time that's my
time this that's my time oh no that's my
[ __ ] job
i thank you what do you have you can't
see that bruce lee
michael jordan
hold on
go ahead please please tell me why i'm
going to roost
your argument because
if you want to go off statistically
who's the best athlete of all time
uh wayne gretzky
the most dominant figure [ __ ] words
then bruce look at the shots
that's a better athlete let me tell you
something stop stop saying he's my
favorite so he's not my favorite excuse
me dude hold up the 150 the 150th ranked
dude would beat the [ __ ] out of sharing
or venus destroy it yeah destroy it no
not the 150. no you can't though
those are facts no
150. that's not true
what is wrong with you
he might be no
you believe in [ __ ]
[Music]
but you know who's the greatest athlete
be careful now the dude that like wins
the olympics in the uh decathlon then
who's jenna used to win yeah
that's the dude ally
caitlin
when he was bruce jenner's toxic
that that that the guy that wins that is
the best athlete that's what he's doing
did you steal some of tyson's troops bro
you think that's true that's insane no
no no just talk to caitlyn at the uh
coliseum
and caitlyn said the greatest ass you
are breaking my heart and the person
that does that how many people compete
in that they do ten events brandon if he
decided to do it would win that event no
bro you tell me he's not better not
feeling caitlyn
you gotta do all that stuff true you
might
crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm assuming everybody's on true until
i'm always sober
who knows doesn't matter but that person
is still the best athlete in the world
you tell me that the dekalb
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
[Music]
the commercials used to be a big deal
are they still a thing now is that a big
deal anymore i don't know i know pete
davidson is doing a lot of stuff for it
there's supposed to be some fire
commercials but
[Music]
bro why didn't you tell me ahead that
all my sugar boy pulls this [ __ ] man all
right fellas remember moneyline has
given out 25k a quarter that's a hundred
grand over the course of super bowl all
you got to do is download the moneyline
app right now get your money raw tag
going follow us on social and comment
with your money war tag right now 25k
we've already given out 25k the next
winner is coming up stay tuned make
money watch the stream with us it's that
easy money line download the app right
now
damn bro you boys broke my heart with
that best athlete combo i don't wanna
really i don't wanna rehash it
you said some crazy [ __ ] man well you
said the craziest [ __ ] bruce lee the
best [ __ ] yeah i might believe that i'm
insane fights [ __ ] this might be the
best
define what athlete is that's the
problem you have to you have to compete
you might be the best philosopher
you might be the best mind well that see
that's everybody's definition of the
athlete is different so you got to show
so then jordan peterson's great ass so
what is this you got to show on iron
mapping how many of this is your deal
i can't you're showing don't you just
say i can't
[Laughter]
[Music]
she's the best female athlete of all
time no that's the problem is a female
she's the best if
serena williams the best athlete if you
put her mindset in anybody you have
michael jordan
she's the greatest so we can't it's hard
for gender if we're going by athlete
based on mindset it's michael jordan
serena williams
oh damn yeah he blew that knee up
his hair looks dope though that's not
good
don't look good at all
[Applause]
out of all the times to do it out of all
the freaking time to do it
acl mcl
39.
39 no they're going to go super cup
first don't go for it cooper county buy
one eastern washington runs fine back
side
[Applause]
mike what was your bet mike
he got straight up you got the bingos
right straight up
i like that bit
you like how the game is going right now
for your your bingo i didn't like that
pat that pass just you ain't
[Music]
mike we talking 50 g's on this game what
are we talking about
i was gonna bet something in that
quality but they understand about five
[Laughter]
yeah
i should have brought my whiskey man
all your boys are gonna text during the
stream all right
after talking all that trash about best
athletes now you jump on your phone
because he embarrassed you boys are wild
he's embarrassed
both people
i'm not wrong
i really believe
[Music]
get out come on stafford
yeah that's a veteran move it's a
veteran move
mike say hi to v hey v how you doing
buddy
i'm doing well i'm doing well see you
guys
[Applause]
[Laughter]
b marshall do you know did that hedrick
hedrickson the the captain for bengals
was he on ohio state when the bozo was
on
are they the same class i think so but
but i really don't know i played with
him my last year oh he's a snug yeah
in 2018 he was on the bench damn that's
right that shows you what kind of
monsters in the nfl bro he was sitting
on the sidelines
he wasn't addressing him sitting
cause that's all y'all
[Music]
here we go third and fourteen starting
fourteen
oh
[Music]
continues to get richer that's exactly
what you said what's going on
the rich continues my boy staffers what
do you need to do
what does mike know about football
what does he know that i don't know team
gritty
team gritty how does he pick the
cincinnati feeling good he's rolling
another blunt
look look
mike's move man
that's what is the psychedelic mike how
many of those you smoke a day you think
[Music]
yeah
five i'm 50.
no way i'm trying to work with my
numerous times i mean no he doesn't know
he's smoking
he don't finish him
that's all i do
because
that's why they don't finish something
thanks brother
[Music]
mike you think you're 15
mike you live in la vegas newport
i lived in vegas
i moved out here for my daughter to play
tennis in newport beach now we're moving
to boca raton for my daughter to play
tennis let's go that's where i live yeah
that's where we going
florida i'm a trainer huh come to my
facility
yeah for my daughter she wants to be a
tennis player wins
[Music]
um
the end of
this month next month my channel save
money on that we got aaron mike coming
to south florida baby let's go i bet the
santa's here
i live 20 minutes away yeah
yeah
let me get one of these real quick
[Music]
yeah and physical therapy athletic
yeah we do all that of course
you got to
are you doing man come here rocco
it's rocco mike he looks just like you
man
that's my boy
and he wants to be a golfer he is a
golfer
what someone told me to tell you is
ducky cash not drake
i don't know lucky hash
dunky cash who met
i'm sorry i don't know son we got we got
the we got
tiger woods 2.0 right here say hi say hi
to the people come here
come here tell us about your game we got
the microphone where's the microphone
come over here right here in between me
and dc because we don't want your dad to
jump in this conversation right now come
here
give him a gift boom boom
all right hello so we got young him
right here young and tell us about your
game what's up brother um it's going
pretty good i'll start my tournament in
march 12th you think you can beat me
yeah
oh you see you got your dance man
what's up man
hold
[Music]
y'all know what time it is
you know what time it is no might know
what time it is
[Music]
oh
oh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
about to get this boy here we go
this is the best wire receiver in the
game three years from now give us your
prediction
who's going to win the game talk to us
man i got the rant i got i got the rams
going
your your idol odell just went down
you know what i'm saying the bengals
gonna beat your [ __ ] ass man
ain't gonna lie to you you know that
ain't true you gotta watch me
watching what's up watching look at this
[ __ ] look what's happening
[Music]
got [ __ ] i've been talking young [ __ ]
[ __ ] when we gonna see the jets in the
super bowl
man y'all just two two and a half or so
man we loading so that's right this dude
right here is next level i don't i'm
already mic'd up gold feet he ready you
gonna lead the lead to the jets to the
super bowl manifestation we're putting
in the work he grind hard you keep going
first he's fighting together
not really too much in the prediction
it's about what we're about to do
enough said now we go back to the
broadcast we got jennifer lopez emmitt
smith
watching live
and this is my team right here jts baby
jets
hey
enjoy your life all right here we go
guys hey
what we got to understand this this is
elijah moore
elijah moore tell these people
what round you went last year
you sitting there in new york with with
zach wilson and tell these people what
y'all learned
i mean i went i went second round
really went first in my head you know
really went number one really went top
ten
man we just about to be legendary he's
got two in there that's it so so elijah
we're sitting here watching the super
bowl you're idle now i wouldn't say your
idol guy that you study and look up to
odell you train odell beckham jr go feed
global down here in south florida how
did it feel seeing odell go down in the
biggest moment of his playing career
it's not something you want to see
but yeah we we always gonna prevail
though you know we pray pray we prayers
up so we good everything's great man
yeah we was on the way here so we didn't
see exactly i'm getting text messages
we'll get a little update but you know
we're gonna let god handle the rest
that's awesome we got goldy global make
sure you go get the merch and support we
got elijah moore next level thank you
how are you feeling all right and
everything good
for real yeah
[Music]
man
bless us for all of us man enjoy today
enjoy your families enjoy the ones
around you tonight
you know what i mean uh we don't have
tomorrow
so for everybody man just stay blessed
and let's go rams let's go bengals
you know what i mean let's go
another 25k on monday night on 20 this
ain't a game
the way you win money you download the
moneyline app
and you can win twenty five thousand
dollars you're not a hundred thousand
dollars okay our boys lakey coney i
think that's the real name lakey coney
just won 25 grand
watson super bowl watching this stream
money line yeah lakey enjoy the money
man
that i would take your money and bet on
the rams but
[Music]
and don't wait too because the way you
win the 25k we're giving away 25k in the
third quarter fourth quarter it's a
hundred thousand dollars total
download the moneyline app right now get
your money raw tag going follow us on
social and comment with your money more
tag
download the moneyline app 25k got
nothing to lose
bro
he lived right there in the plantation
this little [ __ ]
they like they let him walk around like
this
yeah yeah yeah nobody robbed you here
hey so you know he played for the jets
mike mike he played for the jets
we got
[Music]
is
here we go
we got second to ten this is a big down
get him get him
here we go
they've actually done a pretty good job
bro we'll make super cute touchdowns
this is the receiver dude we're talking
about a receiver that's the game
watching him he did what jerry rice did
huh
yeah wide receiver yes but i'm old i'm
retired he's active he's the next one up
what makes cooper cup special man
probably really just his man's patience
he look like he's real real pacing he
understands the zones he understands the
pictures you like that maze is a smart
smart play you see the way talk seaway
interviews man he just knows what he's
doing no he knows football
i love it last question for you before
we let you enjoy your your super bowl
watch party here with with money lying
uh how much does your chain cost because
we're his money line is presenting
sponsor all right and we're talking
about money and financial literacy how
much is this this charm man a little
peace man
[Laughter]
respect
respect
thank you
[Applause]
it's almost half time fellas
oh [ __ ] going down it's almost going
down and for the viewers out there on
halftime we're going to take a little
break you guys enjoy the halftime show
and remember download the moneyline app
in the third quarter fourth quarter
giving away 25k all you gotta do is
download the app moneyline app get your
money roar tag going false on soul stone
comment with your money roar tag 25k
third quarter fourth quarter we've got
two guys win in the first and the second
quarter
it's too easy man to make money
[Music]
that's it man we're about to go to
halftime enjoy the halftime show we're
gonna get a break we're going to fuel up
on food and shrooms and
chronic and some chronic with mike enjoy
the halftime show we will be back for
the third quarter download the moneyline
app make some money we'll see you in the
third quarter
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh no no
what's up everybody thank you guys for
tuning in here we are at the money line
man the lion's den with my money line
baby brandon marshall daniel cormier
money lion brand marshall we haven't i
mean
it's a it's what is it 12 seconds why
did this is
16 35 why does cincinnati have 16
they just scored because i know one two
three four five six oh 20 now 21 is it
21 no 17 i'm sorry
i'm [ __ ] up in math that's the problem
yo what up what up what up what up here
we go
let's let's see
70 yard
towards the ball hey hey b marsh hey hey
mark still eligible to be played that
should be the talk
so we gotta earn your leisure in the
building and the question was why is
this number still even available it's
not up there before the season
i would no i don't want to talk to
nobody for the season
of super bowl we'll never see you give
me a reason oh joe never retired but
this is a great way to go out and i love
that refreshing
retired guys and these active guys what
to do with them
yeah
i want to straight up talk about like
for you coming to the league how is it
making mistakes financially like how did
you learn somebody taught you or you had
to learn on your own
there you go
so what i did was yes
basically like the financial dictionary
and i got these uh these note cards and
on these note cards i wrote down all the
terms
you know what i mean i wrote down even
if it's a spring all these things
and i signed a 50 million dollar deal
but before i would invest my money i
would on every away trip and we're on a
plane to go into the new to the new
england patriots or the jets i would
actually take out all these notes note
cards it's about 50 note cards
got them it's
over it's just we do that's what
stafford does man
it's a wrap i told you guys it's an
eddie bengals i know 19 years ago
so i was studying well you know what was
that
so i would study i would study these
note cards before i wouldn't invest i
had 50 million sitting in the bank
before i would even invest i wanted to
understand 50 million in the bank
basically that's correct
50 million deals and i didn't start
investing until i understood what all
these terms meant what is liquidity what
is like something simple is that well i
want to know the fundamentals before i
sit at the table with these people to
say i'm about to invest your money and
now let's go joe 60 22 interest are
returned every single year so my money's
making money
nah that's that's so important that's so
important man so many people go broke
because they don't understand what you
just said 100 i mean you know when you
think about uh money line that's why
it's important like where is the right
platform for us to go and partner with
to actually help entrepreneurs and
startups or just people who have what
they have to extend it you know i know
from my life expectancy standpoint that
my money is going to last my children's
children if i stick to the game plan
that we implemented 10 years ago
that's key i love what you're doing i am
athlete like you really are transcending
the game and becoming a media mogul too
yeah i mean that's the opportunity bro
like
one time raises all [ __ ] you know to me
i am at this incubator and accelerating
for talent around athletes
that's point-blank period bro you know
it would be selfish of me now if i only
nobody's already done that before in the
podcast space that's right i am at the
la i am at the houston bumby kendrick
perkins l.a you got swaggy p
keenan beazley and it's the same thing
it's
talking about him first conversation we
have the first time
we'll give him
[Music]
joe burrow got that swagger up
ain't no stopping
ain't nothing ain't nothing
oh ain't no no
oh
skirmish ref we're just gonna let it
live
[Music]
watch cincinnati i see aaron donald try
to put somebody there
i like two games and the colors too you
like the colors black and orange
and that's why
[Music]
you got we got you playing football what
would you do
pull back
i would want to be
whatever lawrence taylor was
london
yeah
yeah no no no he wanted to be lt if i
would if i would play football i
wouldn't want to be him yeah
he was letting everything go
[Music]
one of the one of the greatest you're
not going to be scary amazing
i said they're going to go to the boy
three weeks four weeks ago everybody's
watching chase boys miami with lt ltc
there was a husband and wife that was
split up husband was singing first class
white position
first class humility bro great athlete
too
he's going for it a great athlete could
perform when he's hurt
so so we gotta earn your leisure here
what's up brother ladies and gentlemen
so so these dudes yeah they talk about i
mean
fourth and one in the first
quarter literacy and also financial
health and so many other tricks that
would trade
is it close enough
you got those in your career
a lot
so what advice yeah joe
that's getting money right now what
should they do with it how should they
be thinking how should they be
approaching it because we gotta earn
your leisure here well first the thing
you should know i don't care
what kind of family you come from what
status you are there's the art to manage
your money i grew up you know there's no
more of these robber barons because they
got nineteen nineteen twelve the taxes
came and they wiped all those guys out
so brother
um
i like the risk of calmness
it tests your humanity it's like sports
and this isn't supposed to yeah you know
remember was like 87. so doug williams
won and i was like that's my team yep
and i i've been loyal since
three
in 2013
and now
you know this is a public trading
company
you know like
without what i appreciate about
moneyline is the education because i
feel like a lot of us and i'm talking
about black white male female we don't
know
because the one percent is really what
controls every wealth and everything
so i appreciate because the education
component from not only money line but
also
you know it's needed you know coming
from where we come from we're not taught
that just make mistakes because you
don't know what to do
education comes from more than just
going to school but that's what we do in
life we don't we get off the fence and
we make mistakes and we learn from our
mistakes
in order to become a master you first
have to be a fool
you know nothing happens overnight
say that again be in order to become a
master you got it first
yes
food even wanted to accomplish that
hold on it's 33
in the red zone
if you try to block it with one man
there's no chance look at aaron donald
going against the right guard we know
that this is the weakest link on the
offensive line mine it's one on one look
what he's going to oh two of them
literally no there's no two of them it's
one
he got two guys the one guy grabbed two
guys no that's the problem mike how you
going every play put two people on aaron
donald that's like you bro
this dude from pittsburgh pennsylvania
penn hills the the poorest town they're
gonna do it the bangor's gonna do this
[ __ ] again
except 20. 20 mangoes doing this [ __ ]
again getting him over hey who that who
they who they got nfl the game is over
no let's go home mike shut down the
stream no shut down the stream no don't
shut it down here stay right here
[Music]
is taking home fifty to a hundred
thousand dollars on all his best this
fight's far from uh big sensitivity
it's over mike
i did everything you told me to do right
now
i bet the way you told me to bet right
right respect he listened to me
he listened to me it's over
this is not over
hey remember fam we're giving another
25k away with money lying coming up very
soon third quarter giving away 25 fourth
door giving away 25 that's 50k man 50k
we gave away 50k last half we're doing
again this half
right now downloading these beautiful
black people uh app right now and you
got a chance to win 25k you said we're
actually
beautiful black people amazing right
yeah
hey liza pretty much
what you know about liz i love this huh
let me let me
know
have you had her on the show no i meant
this though before
yeah man god bless you y'all out here
[Music]
you don't have my number
you don't know
[Music]
don't give nobody my number no [ __ ] i'll
get tab the [ __ ] though
you're lying that one where
nate you're a liar
[Music]
damn they're doing tattoos
in the back there right now okay well we
can just freak tattoos back here
yeah are we still live right now we're
still live we're live right now anybody
that's here right now we're giving free
tattoos in the back this is crazy
[Laughter]
he's like a lion at the zoo
i don't eat no meat this boy ate meat in
three days he's he can eat like i
haven't ate meat in three and a half
years that's my second yeah
bro you don't understand what's in me is
it nice i wish i had those right i'm on
this carnivore diet right
now
right yeah that's what you told me i'm
starting today i started this carnivore
diet
if you ain't forming it don't eat it
do you know it's in vegetables
yeah which will you tell me what's in
vegetables
there's some vegetables that are
poisonous that'll kill you
meat isn't
a basic consumption of meat alone is bad
everything in moderation meat
fish
um veggies every day every day in
moderation what's your diet besides
psychedelics and weed what's your diet
right here bro mike eight i think i
think it's not realistic not to eat meat
that's my pleasure but i'm really like
all
right
all right let's go ladies and gents now
cause you got a lot of money on the line
well 15 to 20. yes los angeles rams are
trailing by seven and if you know how to
count then you know
seven and the third are down by seven in
the third it's the third quarter okay
ten minutes left in the game
this is a crucial drive [ __ ]
bang bang you're putting a lot of
pressure on 25k he only got five kids
did you download more mike did you put
more on it i told him he said he's
put five only
don't put down twenty five thousand five
mike you don't need more than that you
got way too much money if you make
twenty five fifty a hundred thousand
doesn't matter like you better put the
five down be happy
watch what you're going to do yeah i
couldn't
really
hold on dc
what is this 38 is right okay third
longer
we go for it
we go for it right that's the middle
three bout two it's not long enough to
do the draw or the screen this one we
actually break up
classic back shoulder what happens is
that running back wide receiver runs the
go route okay if the db is over top and
i can't get you to catch it over my
shoulder throw it back shoulder watch
watch watch
marshall this is a pen plate cooper cup
is trying to get the pick he's trying to
get the safety to take him
matthew stafford read it beautifully
through the back shoulder if he boss 55
or too [ __ ] slow how how how much
have do they have to change their game
plan now that odell beckham's out
because cooper they can double cooper
cup remember o'down came in what week 10
week 11 yeah falling though but he
played yeah but they already have the
chemistry and continuity oh dale had to
figure out how to implement it so
they're fine they're fine
thank you so when did this back
shoulders go become so like relevant to
football yeah that wasn't something that
always happened allegedly boomer
osirison turned to cincinnati bengals
ironically the cincinnati bengals are in
the super bowl was the first team to
implement the back shoulder no no sorry
phil sims in the new york giants way
back back then bro it didn't seem like
they were doing it that much on the back
shoulder
yes the commentators just weren't
noticing because bill parcells was the
head coach and bill parcells used to say
if my
636465 wide receiver is open i mean if
he's covered he's open destroyed and
that's where the back shoulder was
discovered
he's throwing the ball good too
good at that oh
[Applause]
this is cool
he was hurt he's been hurt yeah
oh they better watch out still no odell
not back still no elderly tyson
[Music]
so mr mike tyson
oh there's no odell beckham jr
this is devastating where is he at right
so
hopefully it's not an acl or mcl type
cert
and we'll see him recover quickly but
there's no jose beckham jr right now in
the biggest moment of his career you
just said they're gonna be fine
they'll be fine
100
but i'm thinking i'm speaking to the
players
so we understand we're in a position we
know that
when you see most broadcasts these guys
covering the sport they can't relate
so odell can you relate to odell in this
moment i think it's the biggest moment
of his career and he's not he's no more
worse he's the worst
because you understand the spot oh wow
now your second and or third
chance to put any money on this game
put everything on the cincinnati bengals
guy
okay i play with these guys
look at that this game is all over
oh
think about what they did to the
cincinnati bengals last year patrick
last week patrick mahomes
the best quarterback in the business you
got smoking joe burrow on the sidelines
saying
he's calm now
he's caught up dc
he's calm he's no longer nervous
i mean
this guy get him get out
oh
too much pressure too much pressure too
much pressure mike when you start doing
reverse passes it's over too much
pressure yes that's what i take
depression they're going to double
reverse pass it's over they cannot take
the pressure my boy super comfortable
he's scrambling
look at the pressure
come on cooper cup play quarterback in
high school you got to hit that cooper
cup
his wife knows it see football players
know the moment this is a big moment we
needed that first down
they're good
uh
it's kind of like how you was earlier i
didn't get 16 years it was like how you
was earlier
when earlier when i was fighting you and
i hit you with the hook and you was like
ah like okay this football player he
might
[Music]
no i can't absolutely
awesome 100 yeah introduce yourself man
yes my name is tejas i'm a tick tocker a
couple drinks in right now and have a
fun a couple fun questions
all right
all right
between
but i got a couple fun questions for you
all okay about the super bowl right it's
a competition between you all okay all
right
the first question is
how many pounds of potato chips are
going to be eaten today
in the nation how many pounds of potato
chips are going to be
oh 10 000 tons yeah that's times two
thousand oh see
you're a money lion
do they pay for that what what is that
what is it young man
11.2 million pounds of potato chips
what's that divided by two thousand i
don't know
call the money like guys
eleven million divided by two thousand
what do we got
oh that's not enough that's it all right
second question how many chicken wings
are eaten today
chicken wings what do you got how the
[ __ ] i know
i'm with tyson on this i'm sorry about
this [ __ ] five million 25
million yeah 225 million 25 million
20 business prices right i go 30 million
30 million so listen yeah no let's look
come on let's think about this
there's 120 150 million
people
viewing live the super bowl i'll say one
two three four the number one food yeah
each person averages five chicken wings
that's it
twenty are going to eat okay so that's
500 million let's do
what is the number 250 million 250
that's the number 1.4 billion chicken
wings are eaten today that's a lot of
dead chicken hey you're a business major
this is what i do at school and i'm not
a business major i'm a football manager
i just do business
hey great case study
all right at the final question
[ __ ] right here how much money
is los angeles making today because of
the super bowl they're losing right now
i don't know let me tell you why they're
like no not the city not the city though
let me tell you
about this oh cause the new la rims made
the super bowl their home team
so you got to think about travis knowing
the airlines
the hotels
so
when
six weeks ago
every everything was times five
when the rams won the nfc
north the nfc okay conference
everything was cut in half by cut cut by
half all right
because everybody's here already yeah
the people are here you're gonna have to
travel that's right
one and a half billion dollars how much
billions yes
billions billion billion i'll say two
billion billion is that two billion nine
hundred and something
how much is the city of los angeles
making because of a super bowl i don't
give a [ __ ]
you're the closest five hundred million
dollars
this freaking guy is the businessman oh
yeah and you know what i am
i'm the freaking hater of the freaking
army
all right like i'm gonna go get it let's
go
you're you just turned 21. uh three
months ago but i'm still trying drinks
you got a recommendation for me i don't
know too much oh whiskey just 18.
tiger thing is it a tequila no it's an
american whistle everybody watching
right now tiger thing
go we're gonna find it what can we find
is japanese it'll be online i'll blast
out we have distribution all over the
nation
[Music]
you're 21 right 21. when mike tyson
or b or dc drives their company
we need the support
because mike tyson is also employing
300 400 people
and those 300 400 people are making
their communities better so we thought
when we talk about generational wealth
we got to support i mean what does that
even look like right right only he would
not like what 100 million look like mike
yeah it doesn't fill this building up
it doesn't fill this room up no no a
couple briefcases
with 100 100 building doesn't fill this
room up really 100 million 100 million
wow
wow that's crazy he's only with that
touchdown mike the only one that doesn't
have 100
that's my my give me a million right now
what's holding you back from giving me a
million what i got to do to get a
million from mike tyson
by eating that fruit like give me 500
thousands start rolling joints for them
yeah
yeah
you might get some gas on those
psychedelics frogs going dude we got it
right here
i can't do too much
here
okay
right
[Music]
all right get up all right sit down come
on get the [ __ ] out man
thank you nice to meet you nice to meet
you thank
you you bro that young man came in here
got bobby slain bobby marshall i'm
forced to smoke weed with my guy
man
shut the [ __ ] up
why are you talking
[Laughter]
mike talking about when it's over
it's second and eleven just give me five
yards stafford that's it bam he gave me
five yeah
you got your money that's funny i just
want to still break them
you want to break them yeah and make
that's fine
why did you pick the cincinnati bengals
i'm sweating laughing at this guy
they had a history of coming back from
behind
so i reached my money on somebody like
that why because i know they wanted real
bad to desire to win
they were down the last three weeks to
make it to the super bowl they overcame
all right we got three about less than
three minutes left don't forget we're
giving away 25k in this third quarter
we've already given away fifty thousand
dollars 25 third quarter 25k in the
fourth quarter
all you gotta do is download the
moneyline app right now man it's super
easy let's say you win 25k like i did
download the moneyline app mike's gonna
lose 5k like i did get your money roar
tag going follow us on social and
comment your money war tag 25k i'm
getting away 50k let's go like i did hey
for anybody for anybody
[Music]
tell us who you want to come sit next to
me
who's going to get punk by myself
send somebody over here moneyline for
mike to talk to you who's getting
[ __ ] nuts
mike why the hell is your feet so big
oh damn we got three times
[Laughter]
shaquille o'neal
he's so tight bro you know you guys know
this as athletes mike is so tight he
look it's like attention i'm not gonna
start stretching i stretch every day why
you so tight huh why you so tight no
need for me to be tired
why does he want my foot
i can't take this [ __ ] back where is 15
don't hit me mike don't hit me with the
hook dog
yo
you're wearing bigger size than me
six four
five size 14
14 triple e yeah
that means it's white as [ __ ] hey that's
why the women love mike tyson oh
[ __ ]
is it true you know yeah you know what
big no a big feet women i know what big
feet means
big
[Laughter]
huh
i'm the worst you know worse
are you like are you are you into four
play
are you
one yeah are you in the fourth place he
said are you getting you know what i'm
saying you take it like are you psycho
and analyzing me [ __ ]
huh yes
what do you want to know that's what we
talking about like you got rear size 14
and you five two you want to see my dick
it gets real sorry
okay mike love man he's gone no
i remember
that alone bro you gotta leave my head
he might hit me with a hook you better
leave that man alone i ain't scared of
him
i was like oh hey
i'm sweating
bro y'all gotta leave michael on dogs
you wanna scoot through the middle then
it wants to scoot down they want to
screw up
who knows mike is another man you made
fun of look how you keep messing with it
man
mike is coming back we're good and then
it might come back and you come with the
[ __ ] i'm going to knock mike's ass
out
here's the thing i think he's
self-conscious about his biggest don't
[Laughter]
ball
mike this is big it's third down it's
starting again hold this watch it's a
big moment champ
mike you got a lot of money on the line
down you keep saying that the cincinnati
bengals is up but at any moment this
game can flip you have von miller this
is the problem
what he's doing to this right tackle
that's called a t e
that's a t e stunt
the defensive end comes out
you're so worried about aaron donald got
by the day for the tackles come in
and boom we got a sack oh look at this
[ __ ] 42. this is
empty we need a big green that's coming
off
get the ball out quick oh that ain't
[ __ ] you said yeah
that's all he needed right there dude
you hear mike mike talking about like my
talking about that's all we needed right
there
why are you [ __ ] here
hey mike tyson toad
there we go
i wish mike thank you
big moment in the game right here hey
mike
whenever you do that frog stuff how long
does it last huh how long does it like
last the psychedelic 20 minutes
but you're going to feel like a 2000
hour
you're going to feel like 2 000 years
hey mike mike mike is it a drop or
you're licking the frog no you drop
smoking oh smoke
but like it only lasts 40 minutes
i'm going to take you right to god
really but it makes it kind of like go
like different
it helps you rise to your highest
potential
yeah look at mike d.c try it i was a
junkie i was on the joke i was on
cocaine i was like oh dinos i almost
died i did the toad
look at me
this is my party
i was od and almost dying
successful business every day
huh everything changed
y'all guys know you guys read about me i
mean i was [ __ ] up i was dying now i
don't even i can't believe this [ __ ]
[ __ ] paid me to have a party
it's all happening
[Music]
that's crazy yeah cincinnati's winning
though
they're about to be losing though i bet
you ran score this big drive right here
it's also only for math
they got the game a lot of people coming
a lot of people coming into this game
we're giving away 25k kids let's go
download the app moneyline
and you know what we just gave away 25k
so you missed out
don't be sad just giving away 25k in the
fourth quarter tiffany duke just won 25
thousand dollars with moneyline hey
people really looking at this [ __ ]
that's simple right
unless you're overly rich you should be
downloading this app people really
we got thousands of people watching
right now
yes
of course you're mike tyson this is
awesome [ __ ] that's what he sees
four quarters mike smoking on the blunt
everybody mike it's the fourth quarter
hey this is the championship rounds
right now are we live right now we're
live
hey everybody watching right now
this is the championship round
the fourth quarter you're going to see
53 guys on the sidelines holding up the
four and what that means and what that
symbolizes is that
this
is what champions
okay
where's my character right there he came
back mike it's my life
can i be the exclusive sponsor of toad
here
my name is hey ask him
you gotta do business with mike mike
real now
what you're looking for how much you
looking for that's that young man is
blitz how much you looking for smoking
oh bro
this young man bro you ain't rushing for
a fraternity
you're high enough so that's pretty high
well inhale be responsible hit that [ __ ]
there we go
it's trump mike's a problem it really is
hey
young man have you smoked weed before
yeah okay
you smoke weed every day
no okay it's good we're gonna be hot
don't worry we're stopping
you're stopping there you're
what the [ __ ] is this liquor i i drink
tequila you smoke weed
how about you kill the guy i deal with
that you good with that yeah you got to
educate me though and i'm not [ __ ]
because no no no mike i do believe from
an anxiety depression standpoint
and stress management
psychedelics and marijuana i can learn
from it and i can embrace it
for real so like that's real and that's
why i love listening to you
in hot boxing because you're educating
people
i'm just getting high [ __ ]
mike what are you going to do with the
money when you when the cincinnati event
what are you doing
excuse me
what are you doing with the earnings
from your
your your bet it's five thousand
dollars what are you doing with that
money i'm going to disneyland
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i love you i'll get out of here
yeah get out for it might get you down
to that pool you stay on the straight
narrow young man no more drugs hey man
stay away from people like this group
stay away from people like this group
yeah yeah you're gonna be young
you'll be good
here we go
third and seven
empty formation they went for it all
they wanted that's a big box fade
that's that's that's jefferson his
father
was a legend at the university of
central florida and then also with the
detroit lions he's a wide receiver coach
right now in the nfl oh wow let's do
this next level but it's in the
bloodline [ __ ] in the bloodline 100
but if that's odell beckham jr he comes
down with this now we're missing odell
beckham the reality is eli apple is
terrible
uh
you know football
but you know eli airplane regarding [ __ ]
i'm going to say facts and i'm going to
move on
[Laughter]
hey that's dc one of the greatest
fighters of all time we're talking about
ufc
this dude knows football he's talking
about eli apple and why this guy was
able to go from the saints and not a
cincinnati bengals and still give up
flames
second down oh my god mike what's going
to happen what's the outcome man we got
13 minutes left
we have a lot of time we got a lot of
time talk to the people what's happening
what's wrong what's going to be the
outcome hey listen right now they have
gotten out there fighting with one
another not really any techniques and
becoming successful
we're gonna hope um
in the next probably the third down will
get better i think he's 34
[Laughter]
hold up fellas it's the fourth quarter
we've got another 25 thousand dollars to
give out
25k is going out download the monday
live
get your money raw tag going follow us
on social comment using the money uh
roar tag do all that download the video
oh my man it's your last chance to win
25k we've given out 75 000 during this
entire freaking
streaming whatever you want to call it
all right look we're gonna we're scoring
a minute obj's in the street close oh
man
it's bad
he looked like he was tearing up
oh he's a huge asset to the team yeah he
is yeah he is
[Music]
it's just odd seeing the bengals in the
super bowl
[Music]
i mean
was the last time they played the super
bowl
the bank like the 49ers was like icky
woods
and boomers
icky woods was the running back
that's bad and he had his dance remember
the icky man you know what he danced him
and his mother had a commercial
you remember the icky do the icky
shuffle [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i'll do it
mike said he ain't doing no icky shovel
mike's a legend
[ __ ] no michael i'm never gonna get this
job again
oh no
we're one and done after this life
i'd encourage the guy i don't bully the
guy on television
that's not a good responsibility
i'm not a good leader okay it's your
party
not a good leader
we just follow suit it's not like he
wanted it though i think he was a good
mic
jeff's not a good he's not a good leader
[Music]
[Laughter]
get his
ass vaughn miller you know what hey bud
listen bing for real real football
here's the deal though
oh no that's not good
get us hurt
get up joe
wow they all went down good that's not
good mike i bet that's a lot of money on
the line you got to win without joe oh
you're not winning that joke that back
up
guaranteed man this is not good people
oh it's on the all my sister oh oh
that's a
oh hell yeah it's on the bengals but
here's the things
here's the deal people look at this this
is vaughn miller one of the necessary
presidents
mvp super bowl 50. look at that get into
joe burrows twisting him up there's no
reason he had to hurt him like that not
necessarily
no that's not unnecessary roughness
that's just football mike no he hurt him
too bad no it's not necessary oh my
goodness mike you can't even fight you
can't play football in these times
not that bad the guy
mike is right it's a 16 billion dollar
industry don't hurt the quarterback joe
borrows the face
mike is right hey they better hold these
guys man
whoa
here we go
all right man you know what i'm gonna
like that be i don't like seeing odell
on the sideline no it's not
so here here's the deal folks right now
with joe burrow's feeling
no that initial shock you think my
career is over or this game is over and
then once the pain subsides and you're
like oh i can still do it that's
[ __ ] we'll know in the next 10
minutes if joe burrow can finish this
game you better put up with that facial
expression so that initial reaction
it's like that pain is so tough you know
that
and then you're like [ __ ] you think as
an athlete my career is over the game is
over that adrenaline
and i guarantee you joe burrow's a
gangster guaranteed doesn't sit out
right
it's like what happened to me and you
were fighting
yo
yo put me in the choke your ass will be
asleep
you think so i would do you hey you
remember hey how many how do you think
i'll last
in an actual fight yes
[Applause]
i would say 35 seconds
i would shoot
so okay you should have my legs you're
getting my legs in what's going to
happen let's drop cage
[Music]
a little bit don't don't chuck me out
let me feel the vibe
you feeling me
yo
bro
bro you feel like oh my god that seven
seconds and you just go to sleep
that's it you go to sleep bro you just
did that and i said oh my goodness
like it goes in your neck
like i felt my damn what is this called
it yeah
i thought that that [ __ ] in my head
hey you want to learn it ask mike tyson
if you could practice so
[Music]
yeah
tell mike you just wanted to choke and
see i'm like you just learned the joke
powerful bro it's like this yeah it's
all technically what's that what's my
play if i if a guy get me that fight
hand fight you gotta fight two on one
chin now
chin down fight the top hand
is this one they can't let my hands you
can't let my hands lock baseball bat two
on one yeah
he's just like habib oh charles charles
oliveira do bronx there you go if
charles lavera gets your neck it's over
look look that's why you always see
muscle member you put that guy i got a
small little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this guy is crazy man
i like do you have it oh
receiver making contact like that all
right i love the steel receivers
my nervous system i got too much money
see if mike wants to let you check it
out
he just hey dc just put a chokehold on
me and mike like two seconds he asked me
like he said put the choke on i gave him
a little taste man
he went like that
he's a [ __ ] master kiss [ __ ]
the joke yeah and the man he likes
he likes pain
i do you like pain yeah he enjoyed pain
but don't do it in a bad way like so
freaking
like that's in sport and sports like
you're able to push through
whatever
you you want to get in the ring you
wanna go 12 rounds i'm going 12 rounds
hey you know what if you want to go to
ufc and three freaking [ __ ] ass rounds
the first 30 seconds of those [ __ ] ass
rounds didn't pass out
against dc
no no i'll give you a journey
two rounds out last with dc two rounds
two rounds ten minutes yeah
here's the thing you might drop me i'm
not afraid of you putting me out so i
might knock you out
because oh man i like your choice hey be
mark
i like your take on bruce lee better
than this
i love this you're not listening
they might not listen that's like me
trying to guard you on the football
field no it's not it is it's a fight
it's like me trying to guard you the
football field mike tell him it's a
fight
i can't go on a football field and chase
him to not stop and make a touchdown
he's going to make a touchdown on the
next
you're going to destroy it but you're
telling me that you can go inside of an
eight-sided octagon and go 10 minutes a
week no
but the best some of the best fighters
in the world haven't been able to go 10
minutes that's right but you're going to
do better than them yes
you're crazy i like your confidence
because it comes down to mindset
you know what you don't know who you are
it's because you're mine my mind is
strong but i know
i know i can't guard you on that
football field bro no but in fighting
yeah and fighting yet no not about
taking a punt it's about
you say this about that no no it's not
everybody
everybody's a champion until they get
punched in their mouth let me see
when you get in that ring any kind of
fight when you get in that ring and
think you're a tough guy and you try to
get in that ring you better be helped
you better be careful you don't forget
of a heart attack [ __ ] they get tired
now what do you mean
[ __ ] everybody watching you i played in
front of
we're in there with no clothes are we
not underwear fight
barefoot you as bear you as you are as
bad in the world make the fight no shirt
make the fight enough
talking beat marshwatch
make the fight make the fight make it
happen now
make the fight mate i feel like yeah
he retired for two years i'm retired for
two and a half it's it's even gonna
start saying please i'm sorry
[Laughter]
what you need how many meals you need
tell mike what you need right now you're
gonna start you're gonna start
apologizing everything mike oh hell yeah
no no
then i feel the obligation then to go
and try to guard you on the football
field and i'm not
[Music]
look at his face he's actually serious
what is that
shake shack oh i can't what is that
what is it i thought i thought you're
saying more whiskey on ice
that's what
you know what i would love to do though
for real
i'd like to match you up with somebody
else no no no no i just wanted to come
just mess around love involved like you
know what i'm saying come here
respectable come to the gym and we just
uh
yeah but i could tell that you've done a
little bit of boxing yes yeah
i can tell right away from the moment
you have yeah you're moving on you've
hit me you know who i want i went to you
oh what about
gio would be down i just i did a show
with him probably a month ago he's in
shape too
yes thanks brother he owes down that
would be a good one we can watch that
hey t.o in shape
yeah bro
i did a podcast with them
i can't eat those thank you i need might
be drunk
championship rounds damn mike's [ __ ]
first and ten yeah here we go
[Music]
they picked up seven yards now you got
this great second and three you can do
whatever you want you do whatever you
want now and you can take a shot can you
take a shot here
i wouldn't take a shot here really you
don't think you get third and three run
it
you're in control
run the ball get the first down we're
talking about
time and possession control the clock
control the clock yeah we're in the
fourth quarter
that defensive line is built to rush
run the ball let's go come on get it
come on
yes
there we go
that's right it's still manageable
[Music]
hey bee marsh really wants to fight
trillo somebody gets [ __ ] up on mike
tyson what are you about to get
hey mike come to tv mikey
i know you hear me mike
ding ding let's go come on the people
want mike tyson back
you better hope mike don't learn to kick
with that size 14 beat marshall y'all
got to stop doing that on this street
once he gets mad it's over
[Music]
once he gets mad it's over i got him now
he's slow you don't want his
one of the greatest heavyweights of all
time and ufc
doesn't matter yeah like 4k mike tyson
doesn't matter it's just like this joe
nixon
see marshall's wild out on joe mixon
let's go baby underdogs we've been to
underdogs our entire life let's go
second down yeah
fourth quarter seven minutes to go it's
16 or 20. what are we going to do you
got matthew stafford sitting on the
sidelines saying oh my goodness i've
been in detroit for 25 years
here we go
you better chill man all right
there ain't enough tequila in the world
ain't got enough to keep marching i
don't like that
leave iron mic alone i'm gonna hit him
with my knees
at least
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
you better chill bro be marsha about to
learn the hard way
let it chill
we got our mic
we got our mic i thought mike that
should be the problem
b
dc we got 19 keys here
it's another one we talk about money
line we talk about we're here to roll
what's up brother
the chain's dope dog you're changing we
got 19 keys one of the guys in this
space right now that's educating our
guys bro
we talking about these dudes right here
making
a crap ton of money how would you advise
them to watch the game though
you know when we look at statistics when
we look at nfl players we look at
athletes we see a lot of them lose their
money
[Applause]
learning how to keep your money and
advance your money to the next
generation is the key
so whether you got to put in
diversification man you gotta put your
money in nfts put it somewheres go make
you some money in the long term you
understand me that's the game that we're
supposed to play you got to have a trust
set up got to have an estate setup just
interesting
right because it's interesting when you
think about money lying they do nfts
crypto yeah every platform where you
want to bank with them you can do so
many other things so it's interesting as
you say that
nfts talk to me about nfts talk to me
about crypto well it's really just a way
where we can get to own our own you
understand me where you look at
historically systems of control and
manage your money now you get to manage
it for you when you get to manage your
career where if i'm a nfl player i'm
gonna go ahead and take my image and my
likeness and find a way to capitalize on
it outside of my contract and there's a
lot of creative ways that a person can
do that outside the business you
understand me but that goes really for
any and everybody it's one thing to buy
into cryptocurrency nfts allow you to
earn cryptocurrency
in the future
that one over here say that again it's
one thing to buy into cryptocurrency you
understand me but it's another thing to
be able to earn cryptocurrency and if
crypto will be the money in the future
then we got to be tapped into the
digital revolution the dollar is
consistently going down inflation is
very high so we got to make sure that we
not only have financial literacy but
financial liberation
sit with us
so we're here super bowl 56 you got the
los angeles rams the home team for real
playing against the cincinnati bengals
the game is legendary we got a couple
minutes left six minutes seven minutes
left in this game it's going to go down
as one of the greatest games ever i'm
telling you right now i don't know if
odell beckham jr is going to go back in
the locker room and put on the suit i
don't know that but what i do know is
the chair the heavyweight champion of
the world
okay has a lot of money on the line and
i have 19 keys here that's educating us
while we're watching the super bowl
love you
stay right here
that's b that's dc
dc
you know you know 19 keys you just
introduced them to us
hey we're gonna i gotta go to the
bathroom we're gonna take you guys
on a big level i know man what do you do
with money line
uh i don't do anything with them man i'm
a thought leader so i usually teach
those who teach everybody else
i got my own platform
you know just speak truth to power and
at the same time i teach people well
master mindset but also how to utilize
this technology
you know it's it's great to see like
young people
actually you know what
young people like starting to
be more involved in terms of leadership
it's all about knowledge too that's why
this isn't a push of money but i think
about moneyline is they have original
content educating people like oh you
want to buy your first car or yeah
you're buying your first home or
you want to you know your personal
trainer that's how you make the money
just have to hustle
yeah but how old are you 31.
so when we were kids there was they
don't teach you that in school they
wouldn't know what kind of financial
taxes like how to make money i mean i
didn't have any of those things as well
that's why i just had to do
self-education yeah
self-education is a new harvard you
understand me yes sir because we all
went to school and got the wrong
education then we had to relearn and
unlearn everything they taught us in
order to do the right thing and then the
outliers figured it out but now those
outliers can educate the young you don't
have to go through the same [ __ ]
well you know like wealth is a buzzword
but at the end of the day
if we all teach wealth i teach family
first you understand because meaning
ain't no wealth unless you can pass it
down yes sir you understand me and
social well i don't do business without
family you understand me those are the
dynamics that we set up and then we
teach people skill sets to buy assets
you understand me i'm not telling you to
just go get a job i'm going to teach you
a money skill so you can do for self at
the end of the day i just look at the
leadership that we've had historically
throughout the past and i try to figure
out if i can stand on the shoulders that
we can go further and if i got that
blueprint why wouldn't i be able to yeah
and we got phones and technology so we
ain't got no excuses no the information
is it's on you to figure it out
available i mean y'all fighters so i
look at the league
of that and i always look at every place
and i say okay how could you advance
that and how can you take everybody
complaints and instead turn into a
business model
right so it's like
attention is what allows platforms to be
able to convert that
but now you got the ability to create
your own platforms and monetize them you
got the business acumen you got the
skill but when you can merge those two
together then you got everything you
need everything you need
really you can do it all from your phone
you really can't [ __ ] i've been did it
all for my phone there's there's no
excuses
a lot of people put excuses in front of
the opportunities yeah those nice
necklaces too
i huh one
i got one i need a [ __ ] my [ __ ] looks
weak right now i'm only worried all the
time i just this this uh
my my spiritual mentor so i'm gonna keep
that on my neck at all times because you
talk the economic blueprints to black
people in america so i keep that and
then i always wear my crown and
represent knowledge itself
so everywhere i go i gotta be a
reflection of what i stand for my man
well said bro
fourth and one congratulations yeah
thank you man
hey i gotta go in the opposite direction
sweating that five kids with words
my man
but if i can get y'all on the show one
time and i'll love it as well just sit
down and have a high level conversation
we got this weird listen now we don't
got this weird [ __ ] here right
yeah
i'll be march yeah people just wanna
take a [ __ ] he went to the bathroom yeah
champ he went to the bathroom champ well
you've been in a hot second though
champ don't hey champ we got four
minutes left don't get him before we get
on air don't get him on here
those lawsuits broke me down yeah
they broke me down i bet they were fun
though
they broke me down
jim how you got to shape like that
how you got in shape like that you were
heavy for a while
you got in shape like real shape
i did um not running
blood spinning you still run jam
yeah i did blood spinning
okay how'd that work
the blood spilled it they take your
blood out
you are opening it all up
put it back in and that's the noise
build up the energy in the blood i'm i'm
what they call it again called prp prp
but another word
they call it another plasma plasma
replacement yes
stem cells
themselves okay and that's how you got
in shape though yes you're running like
mike
yeah on the treadmill
i bet you i bet you're huffing with the
feet
good
jim you spar still are you just trying
to hit fast no i hit the back but
periodically
you can't run every day like you used to
because you start breaking you down
you're hitting back everything
sometimes you got to take two days off
and come back
all right we're playing now right come
on mike you're nervous about your money
that's right you nervous about your
money
no you're good
hey mike whenever you fight no young
y'all run a mile for every every round
a mile per round
no um
12 miles nobody got paid more to spar
with me no i'm saying like when you were
running on your road work yeah did you
want one mile for every round for like
12 miles no i did i ran 20 miles before
20 miles yeah i did 20 miles before
that's that road work
that's a real road work go cool come on
get this guy that's receiving the nfl
mango
keep on the
look at all these people rooting for
these people man
so right now we're getting into
situational things the l.a locals gonna
stick together you're feeling
situational
i got to focus on the situation at hand
oh no
boom we throw it down mr relax now we're
second down and manageable okay
we're in the red zone there's so much
going on right now they're trying to
score these guys trying to score
yeah of course
mike what do you want right here do you
want to laugh or do you want to run
i don't know they're putting pressure on
the bingo
it's only
we got three by one got one run back in
the backfield they choose a run so they
they didn't listen
they stacked them right with that oh
[ __ ] wow now you give joe pearl with a
bum knee
about a minute 30 at that time
what's up
free time you're a money guy yes sir how
much money is being spent
or what's going on right now in the city
of los angeles because the super bowl is
millions
it is in the billions right millions
like you wouldn't believe it
they just said
it might be tens of billion we gotta we
gotta we got a spending problem
everybody in america got a spending
problem well it's inflation right now
though i know but we need to have an
investment problem you understand me
that's the solution is like they put out
there that black people got 1.6 trillion
spending power but we lost 14 percent of
our net worth it's because it's spending
meaning it's going out if you circulated
coming back to poor origin if you invest
in this giving you a return on your
money
invest in real estate probably the
safest place not just real estate right
now real estate probably gonna have a
bubble for everything that's going on
it's very high you understand me uh but
you got crypto you got gold you got nfts
you got blockchain technology you
understand me you got stocks right
historically stocks and businesses go
get you the best returns but now you got
crypto if you know how to invest it in
the right way and then after all this
regulation happen it should be good at
least when you're looking at the time
it's not going to work
we have to look at the reality too
everybody's not going to get rich
percentage is not high in that
perspective but that's why i say if the
average person just invests 500 or a
thousand in bitcoin if it continues to
go up this way you will be all right
there's not enough bitcoin for every
millionaire to own one
you understand me so you don't have to
have a lot before standard of living in
the future you got to hunt something
it's about education listen if you have
500
i don't know anything about this but i
have it
i know see that's the key there you go
i don't know the smart people around you
who help you yeah
i don't know if it's gonna be worth
anything if i prepare for the future
even though i don't know what it is well
sure the only key against the risk right
now is diversity so you gotta invest in
everything that's the only way it's
gonna work out that's what your money
matters is that's not the rich that is
the wealthy richest frame of mind you
can have a billion dollars to be poor
yeah
you know yeah i mean you know i look at
welfare's the abundance mindset
if you balance you can go in the
negative or you can go into positive but
if i'm abundant i got enough to give
away i know but wealth is the value that
you have in yourself i'm not wealthy you
know i mean because i'm valuable i'm
valuable because i'm wealthy well see
that's in the mental aspect but in the
power aspect
of your ability to be able to move power
in energy collectively like this but
that's rich you know in order to guide
me the rich didn't get there by saying
they were from the mental perspective
absolutely mentalism is key i develop
it's the precepts every everything in my
mind that's what my womb is that's why i
give birth but then i'm gonna work it
into existence that's my formula
so i teach people to mindset eighty
percent mindset twenty percent skill set
but if you ain't got the mindset you
ain't gonna never develop the skill set
to execute you and someone listen
i don't have the mindset well back then
when i was the young i don't have the
mindset right but you got a belief yes
and i have and i have the money
i don't have to educate them
money the sister uh jackie
told me some great stories about you
when you was younger so you always had a
vigor you mean to believe in yourself
well energy where you gonna go forward
regardless
people don't then you converted at
different i want to be up more than
anybody wants me to be down yeah
and there's a lot of people that want
you down in here here we go b-mart it's
not gonna happen oh it's wide open
listen this is gonna be the bingos okay
we're in the red zone
everything's about numbers the numbers
game right now is not favoring
but los angeles
this is what you got to do this is what
josh mcdaniels of the new elite patriots
that's pressure man too much pressure
yeah man bro it's not the first read
that quarterback got to get outside the
pocket and receivers got to keep running
to actually score a touchdown
keep moving watch this boom
why why not five yards well what you
gotta understand is these db's don't
have to backpedal enough right now
they can sit there at the goal line
remember the back in line is their
friend another defender how many throws
do they have left
they got two they got third down they
got fourth down
mike tyson
okay is asking brandon i like watching
mikey because he getting better on the
bangers yeah i'm just over here oh yeah
mike better than the big one i'm going
for the big one mike just wanted his
money i was watching this on this
[ __ ]
three by one running back in the
backfield watch this running back
picking up ten watch this running back
no
oh
that's [ __ ] right that's [ __ ]
that's both ball that was all ball yeah
they're gonna get him on the left mike i
think they're gonna get him on the left
one yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
wilson's been playing a phenomenal game
let's see if it's look look look look
look look oh you can't do that we can't
i can't look at this
hold on timeout is it within five yards
nope if it's with this stop it's not
it's not all right then it's a penalty
mike that was that old referee man
you don't know
if he wasn't winning
and still get that [ __ ]
oh he's talking [ __ ] he got lit up you
got mint oh can't believe it
you know why because 70 of the time mike
when you blitz matthew stafford touch he
converts
seven is your target number that's real
those that's that's learning that's
understanding the game 70 of the time
teams who blitz matthew staff that's the
best i've been like
man cooper cup eastern washington yeah
but he got him in the face well michael
kiev loved hanging out watching me dude
about that
[ __ ]
oh this uh i'm uh
mike talk to us about now talk to us
about branding and marketing
branding and marketing
yeah
you are your brand is who you are
my brand is not me i'm the brand
so i have to represent my brand new web
in in order to accomplish what i want to
accomplish to be the best in the world
of what i do
i got a question for you i always kind
of wondered about this you remember that
thing you used to wear was like that cut
towels yeah was that your idea was that
something you guys thought of like the
guys in the 20s and 1915 used to wear oh
really they didn't have roads back then
i always wondered why you wore that it
was [ __ ] cool
and short shorts that's a great question
why is that short shorts
sex appeal
oh the less the
less clothes you have on the more people
come yeah dude that tall thing was like
explaining because i remember that
explain that less clothes we have on the
[ __ ] bill
i know but explain what i mean
we're over sexualized everything sex we
look at yeah that's the [ __ ] everything
everything you look at well i like the
[ __ ] that wow
wow i hit that with nobody knows you
know
my whole life the sexuality but you know
hey just look at the halftime look at
the halftime show mary j blige look yeah
look at the people dressed in here
hey mike when you order one when you
wore the towel and to pop walk you to
the rink that's the most iconic ring one
of all time
today which one when he wore awarded
when he was coming out when tupac walked
into the ring in vegas most iconic ring
walker of all time still what made you
say i walk by eat your babies
because i wanted to
yeah i wanted to
yeah no neighborhood more dangerous than
up here
hanging out
okay
[Music]
who is your favorite arena mgm or
mandolin
madison square and maddie mgm right got
so much history now yeah every time i
fought there you could feel the history
like every time and in the in the
hallways they got all you guys pictures
in there
like from the big events yeah when
you're walking through the hallways to
fight you'd see a picture of you
yeah here we go
second ago when i was before hold
[Applause]
[Music]
that back shoulder is like an uppercut
yeah i'm here all night yeah and then
all of a sudden boom it get me it's
sneaky it's sneaky
no it's your team cincinnati
money line give me a thousand a thousand
thousand it's not bad
right now right now smoking joe you got
it thousand it's
a year 2000
what are we doing
this boy won odds
[Music]
right now it's going to be joe's on the
other side saying it's overnight so fast
though not so fast that's the war going
on looking look at staff yes oh my
goodness i'm out of detroit yeah you
believe that world champion can you
believe that and you got your mark chase
first you got smoking joe burrow over
there
smoking joe is locking one up right now
yeah
that's your bill
we're giving another 25 koa that's a
hundred thousand dollars we told you
moneyline ain't playing man
how do they how do they win the money
how they win the money yeah they'll get
the money
right there's the last one this is it
it's too late now there's a minute 25
left in game aaron johnson you won 25
thousand dollars be smart with your
investments talk to my man right here
yeah man 25k increase your chances of
winning
again
[Applause]
uh-oh
jamarchus
shout out to moneyline thank you guys
okay
man mike what's the name in this dance
i have no idea how's that
bro what is it is that greedy
that's what they do in cincy no louise
yeah lsu boys yeah louisiana
don't take that from us b
that's on jalen too that's just crazy
right now
it's a good game anything can happen
right now man blue 32 hood hut i'm
throwing up side to the left
yeah i like seeing that
that
is not true
[Music]
i'll go straight up 1000 a business out
you got a thousand i got it down all
right
you the money man 19 keys money lying
yeah you know what what's the odds
what's the odds well i'ma tell you man
the best thing you can do right now when
a game is like this
is take your money and invest it in
crypto instead
much better odds i promise i'm trying to
get a thousand from b mars investing
freaking crazy marks that gave what made
a terrible bet smoking german terrible
1000 that's a run it's a run it's a
run it's run
run
there we go first down first down
i told you eric donald bro
ah
[Music]
i don't know why they're running erin
donald
i like a good fight though no opposite
if
if our fighters
if our fighters know that then why
doesn't our office
look hey right here like the coach the
coach now
young head coach taylor fans
he's nervous for fans right this is the
game
it's the game yo brother
i hope nothing gets this true
mr brown yes it's the best
[Music]
oh
[Music]
look at him
he's mvp yeah
two touchdowns game winning touchdowns
money life man
tell the ceo of moneyline to kick his
ass over here
why don't you thousand
tell the ceo not to pay it for him mike
i'm sorry mike lost 25.
yeah five
it's cool for him yeah some people like
doing too much well i don't think you
should never spend more at any given
time winning five or ten percent of your
money especially if it's not an
investment
damn wow what a game though the boy
woodward got a title 40 years old
he's 40 years old bro yeah
that was a fun game though it was a good
game
mike how you feeling out there man you
sad about the 5k or not sure don't like
the losers yeah
you just don't like to lose
a little bit though not even a little
bit
come on
i'm gonna get it back
that's a big win
super cup mvp right
super tough mvp right now
bro he had seven receptions
back
[Laughter]
i guess it's over
the show is over now right the show's
over moneyline thank you guys all the
winners congrats over a hundred thousand
dollars
listen you still download the moneyline
app they have great content on there you
guys it's a smart thing to do shout out
to moneyline shout out to mike tyson
dc
be mars thanks holding it down
love it i love you all
we're out we love you guys
go rams super top fpv
that was love man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
my
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
you